hey everyone this is Kevin from the
chesswebsite.com and if you're looking
for chess openings that you need to be
looking at at 2023 you have come to the
right place I have a mix of openings as
white as black but these are going to be
fun as well as competitive openings that
you need to make sure that you study up
on all of these chess openings we have
specific videos already dedicated to go
much deeper this video is going to go
high level to make sure you understand
what these chest openings are and some
of the high level Concepts but if you do
want to dig deeper make sure you
subscribe to this YouTube channel as
well as you can join our membership site
at the chesswebsite.com but without
further Ado let's go ahead and get into
our list of the seven chess openings you
need to be studying for 2023
coming in at number seven is a fan
favorite it's one of the most popular
aggressive openings and that is the
fried liver attack starts out with E4 E5
and then after Knight F3 Knight C6 then
Bishop C4 getting light Square bishop
and volume to the game preparing to cast
on the king side and also attacking this
F7 Square the F7 Square for black is the
weakest Square early on the game because
the king is the only piece attacking it
now pretty common for black is to play
Knight F6 usually we want to get your
Knights developed into the game and you
can see after they get their dark Square
Bishop evolve into the game they can
cast on the king side but white is going
to look to immediately attack that we
can square on F7 and play Knight to G5
so the bishop and the Knight are both
attacking this Pawn on F7 can be very
difficult for black to hold on to this a
lot of variations that you can get into
from black many of them involve white
just chasing the King around the board
so if you're looking for something thing
and you like to play this Pawnee Ford
usually end up with Pawn E5 and that F3
Knight C6 definitely look at the fried
liver attack
coming in at number six we have the
French defense now if you're thinking I
don't want to play the French defense
have no fear this is more about
attacking the French defense and
understanding what weapons you have to
turn what I think is one of the more
boring openings in chess for black and
turn it into an exciting way that white
can attack their opponent so if you play
E4 your opponent plays E6 and you think
this is going to be a bummer they're
playing the French defense there is an
entire repertoire that you have to
attack the fridge defense one of my
favorites is the ortho shop Gambit which
starts with C4 so if they continue with
D5 we take and then after they take on
D5 we bring our Queen to B3 you can see
very different than any other French
defense you have typically seen so if
you're thinking about improving your E4
opening you need to make sure that you
have weapons against the French defense
so study up on that because there's a
lot of new innovative ways that you can
attack it we have lots of videos that
cover all of these variations to get you
prepared to attack the French defense
coming in at number five we have a solid
defense from black that I don't think
it's played nearly enough and that is
the Karo Khan after E4 popular opening
from white black can play the move C6
now White's usually going to continue
with D4 makes sense controlling the
center of the board but then black can
counter attack with D5
you can either have white push forward
with E5 or the mainline Knight C3
there's an exchange in the center of the
board and then Bishop F5 but
understanding how black can continue and
it really puts white in a different
situation and how they normally like to
play in their E4 opening so definitely
make sure that you have the Karo Khan on
your list for 2023.
coming in at number four we have mile
time favorite opening and that is the
King's Gambit starts out with E4 E5 and
then Pawn F4 giving up material on the
F4 square and after the pawn takes white
has a ton of options as far as how they
want to attack their opponent we have 10
specific videos on how white can
continue in this position and there are
some fantastic ways that white can
respond so I'd highly recommend checking
out the Kings Gambit diving into some of
those variations that you feel are going
to best suit your game that's definitely
going to set you up for a fun and
competitive 2023
coming in at number three on the list is
the most aggressive chess opening on the
list and it's my favorite way to attack
E4 after E5 and they play Knight F3 the
most common line for white we play the
Latvian Gambit with Pawn F5 I don't want
to give too many spoilers on this
there's a dedicated video we've created
just for the Latvian gamut if you want
to dig deeper into that but needless to
say this is a very aggressive line with
crazy sacrifices and it usually ends up
with white being on the defensive which
is not what they are used to doing after
they play E4 Knight F3 so it's if it's
not already on your list make sure that
you have the Latvian game it on your
chess openings list for 2023.
coming in at number two we have the
Petrov defense after E4 E5 Knight F3 we
play Knights F6 now they're typically
going to take here and black has a few
options one you can play the main line
of D6 forcing the Knight to come back
here I think it's important to
understand some of the basics of the pet
drop defense after D6 but then you can
start to get into some more adventurous
lines one of which being the Stafford
Gambit with Knight to C6 the Knight
takes Here pawn takes on C6 and you can
see this opens up the world for black
both the Bishops are now activated the
queen can get involved into the game and
so yes white is up a pawn in material
but black has a lot going for them in
the attacking sense so definitely check
out the Petrov defense it is a fun and
creative way that you can attack this E4
Knight F3 opening from White
coming in at number one we have the
Sicilian Defense Dragon variations the
Sicilian being one of the most popular
openings in all of Chess after E4 C5
from black it's also extremely
aggressive depending on what variations
you play in the three dragon variations
allow you to change up how you want to
play based on your opponent and based on
how you're feeling that day one you have
the typical Dragon variation which after
Knight F3 you play D6 and then they play
D4 you exchange and then after Knight
takes on D4 you play Knight F6 Knight C3
and then Pawn G6
now you could say I want try the
accelerated dragon and instead of
playing the D6 move instead you bring
out your knight to C6 first and after
they play D4 we still have the same
exchange but now we play G6 and then
once you get more familiar with that you
can get into the hyper accelerated
Dragon which says we're not even gonna
play our Knight to C6 first instead
we're gonna skip all those steps and
play Pawn G6 repairing defian kiddo our
Bishop to G7
so those are the top seven chess
openings I recommend you study in 2023
if you haven't already please subscribe
to this YouTube channel it has a ton of
content just like this where we go
deeper into the chess openings so you
really understand how you can play each
of these effectively also if you haven't
become a member at the chesswebsite.com
there's a lot of exclusive content that
goes even deeper into the openings the
tactics the strategy to get you better
at chess definitely check that out even
beyond the YouTube channel I think
you'll find a lot of value there thank
you guys so much for watching the video
and I'll see you guys next time